[clink]
>>Sparky: OK.
I see that Nick and Rich are getting seated,
so I will start by saying good afternoon,
everybody.
And welcome once again to the Android Developers
Office Hours EMEA edition.
We are the EMEA-based Android developer relations
team.
I'm Sparky.
I'm coming to you from Munich, Germany.
And I'm also joined by my colleagues, Nick
and Rich, who are visiting in--where.
Are you in Tel Aviv?
Is that where you are?
>>Rich: We're coming slightly blurry from
Tel Aviv.
Please don't clean your webcam or screens
or anything.
We just have a slightly lower quality internet
connection today.
Hopefully the audio comes through OK.
We're also joined by, here's Nick.
This blur here is Nick's blur.
And this one's mine, Rich.
And we're joined by a blur on the far left,
or far right to you guys, Yossi from ooVoo,
who has been joining us at the GDG meeting
in Israel here.
>>Sparky: Hi, Yossi, wow.
Imagine being in the same building with him.
>>Rich: Yeah, this week he's live with us.
He was gonna join anyway, right?
Just need more bandwidth, so we might as well
do it from the same room.
>>Sparky: That's terrific.
Well, I can see you guys pretty well as long
as you hold stock still.
So, lean back on those support braces that
you got yourselves built and don't move a
muscle and your picture will be just fine.
Oh.
And Matt is asking to be invited into the
Hangout.
How do I do that?
You got it?
>>Rich: I'll take care of that.
>>Sparky: All right.
So, I see that we're already joined by several
people live in the Hangout.
We got Al.
We got Archbrum.
We got Ravi.
Who else has just joined us?
Ravi, Dami, and Richard.
So that rounds out who's live in the Hangout
right now.
Do any of have anything Android related that
you would like to talk about this week?
>>Rich: Can I just check with you, Sparky?
Where was Matt asking?
Is he on the G Plus thread?
>>Sparky: No, he just pinged me.
Oh, he just joined the group chat.
He must be in.
>>Rich: He joined us.
OK.
>>Sparky: Matt, welcome.
>>Rich: There he is.
>>Sparky: Some pretty posh digs you got there,
Matt.
>>Rich: [inaudible]
>>Sparky: That, where are you--?
>>Rich: Please feel free to go ahead and ask
your question.
[pause]
You gonna ask it live or ask it in the chat?
>>Sparky: I want you people to be bold--bold
and assertive.
Ask your questions because I've only got five
questions queued up in the Moderator.
So, if you crawl back on the Moderator, we're
going to exhaust our prepared material quite
quickly.
>>Rich: We have a plan.
If we run out of planned material, we can
go around.
We've got a Hackathon running here at the
moment in Israel.
We can go around with our shoddy internet
connection and see what people are up to at
the Android [inaudible] Hackathon.
>>Sparky: That's pretty cool.
>>Rich: So, Harry has typed through the window.
Maybe he has no microphone?
Has Al got a lower third?
What is going on?
[laughter]
>>Al: I thought I'd give it a try this week.
I can turn it off if you guys want.
>>Rich: No, no.
You go for it.
>>Sparky: I want one of those.
>>Al: I'll tell you how to get it in chat,
Sparky.
>>Sparky: [laughs]
>>Rich: Are you using one of the Hangout plugins
for that?
The lower third plugin?
>>Al: Yeah, I am.
I only just discovered it a couple of days
ago.
>>Rich: Sweet.
Nice.
Everyone should start doing that.
We'll know who you are more easily.
Harry is asking "I want to play a sound when
a user clicks on a button using the sound
form.
It was working well except on my HTC.
It works well except on your own device.
It doesn't create a sound after the act.
with visible for more than three seconds."
>>Sparky: I presume that's "activity."
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Sparky: Hmm.
>>Rich: So it works unless the activity's
been visible for more than three seconds,
or the other way around.
It doesn't--.
>>Nick: Sounds like some sort of race.
>>Rich: Playback to audio hardware, log cast
audio hardware ACM.
Playback is going to standby.
So it works when you hit the button within
the first three seconds and after that it
doesn't work anymore.
Are you pretty much using the example code
for SoundPool?
I've only used it a couple of times myself,
but I just used the sample code, put it in
and used it.
And it was fine.
Have you checked StackOverflow for this particular
issue with your bit of log cat there?
>>Sparky: Hmm.
>>Rich: Sorry.
I'm talking to a chat window live on air right
now.
I'm reading the chats back.
Harry says, "Yes I've checked Stack Overflow"
and yes, he's talking about activity.
Which one is [inaudible]?
>>Sparky: Yeah, I don't know anything about
it.
>>Rich: He's got a StackOverflow issue.
[pause]
>>Sparky: Yeah.
Alright.
Well, it's great that we have the StackOverflow
case.
I don't know if we're gonna be able to really
sort through it live.
>>Rich: [inaudible].
[pause]
>>Sparky: Let's see.
Taking a look.
It doesn't--.
>>Al: It does seem to indicate that it's device
specific and that's a StackOverflow question.
So maybe it's a problem with HTC's implementation
or some of the binary packages they're using
on some of their devices.
>>Rich: The SoundPool's a pretty oft used
class.
I would've thought if HTC had buggered up
the implementation SoundPool, we'd know about
it.
>>Sparky: It does say that he's using Ogg
Vorbis.
So, that's Open Source.
You can't trust that stuff.
[Rich laughs]
>>Yossi: Has he tried to use the media player
object and see if after [inaudible] you'll
still have the object ready for you?
[feedback sound]
>>Rich: Same result with the media player,
Harry says.
It looks like we have another third now.
Now, we'll waste the lower thirds across the
whole of the bottom screen.
I don't think I can have one being a, a live
Hangout host.
>>Sparky: Yeah, I'm drawing a blank on this
one.
I don't know.
This is not exactly my forte.
>>Rich: The notification of the sounds work.
But that's clearly a hack.
I'm just gonna take a look.
Sorry about that.
>>Sparky: It does sound pretty hacky.
On the other hand, it sounds like a pretty
clever hack.
>>Rich: OK.
We don't have an answer for you for that right
now, Harry.
Sorry.
I haven't had issues like that with SoundPool
myself, but then again, I haven't tested on
that device.
So, I'll have a quick look around whilst we
go to our Moderator question.
Go and read out the first Moderator question
with your better internet connection, Sparky.
>>Sparky: Sure.
First question on Moderator is, "Now that
Google Cloud Messaging is in place, is there
any recommended way of benchmarking how an
app behaves for large numbers of receivers
before going live?"
That's an interesting question because it's
only peripherally Android related, right?
I think what he's, if you're talking about
load testing, really what you're looking for
is your testing out the web app via the server-based
application, not the Android client.
And yeah.
It's a web service, so I would say test it
out the way you would test out any web service.
Probably abstract out the Android clients
and maybe just use some kind of a web-based
load testing tool or an Expect script or a
Python script or something.
And hammer at it purely with network-based
requests.
That's my answer to that one.
And as far as the Google Cloud Messaging part
goes, that's, the Google Cloud Messaging is
a service that we are providing more or less
as is and either it can handle your load or
it can't.
And we think it can.
So, GCM, at least as far as its load testing
part, isn't really part of your system under
test.
It's really our system under test.
So, all that you need to worry about is your
Android client and your server app.
And the server app you can basically test
using traditional network testing utilities.
>>Al: It's also probably worth mentioning
that with GCM, it's not worth assuming that
if you send a message out a user is gonna
receive it quickly because people can be out
of service areas, can have their devices turned
off.
So, bulk load testing like that's not really
the best way to go.
It's probably better to test the logic on
the client side for discarding messages, which
have either expired or out-of-date or no longer
relevant.
>>Sparky: Right.
>>Al: You might see, you know, a series of
messages that have been patched up waiting
to be delivered to you.
>>Sparky: Yeah.
And of course, Google Cloud Messaging is designed
to not be a reliable protocol, meaning we
make no guarantees at all that every message
will be delivered, or that messages will be
delivered in a timely manner or in order.
I like to just tell people, think of it more
like UDP rather than TCP.
Packets can arrive in any order.
Some of them can be lost.
And you should design the information that
you're packing into the data to take into
account the possibility that not everything
will get through.
For instance, rather than sending a GCM message
that says, here is the content of your mail,
you send a GCM message saying since the last
time you contacted the server, you have 27
new messages.
Here's a little URL so that you can get your
27 new messages.
If that one gets lost and number 28, 29, and
30 come in, you send another one that says,
since the last time you contacted the server,
you now have 30 new messages.
And that way your messages can be cumulative
and you aren't reliant on every single one
getting through.
>>Nick: The other thing to think about is
if you're worried about sending a GCM [inaudible]
that goes to thousands and thousands of people
and you're worried about them harrying the
server, you can build in some jitter code.
Like, don't let it all go at once, but time
phase it so you're calling GCM at specific
times.
Or, in your client code, you can put a broadcast
task over one and add some jitter in your
new client code so maybe, bound to be over
a minute, you'll call and get it [inaudible].
Ten thousand get requests all at once, so
that's something to consider.
>>Rich: And also, one of the new features
of GCM over cloud to cloud device messaging
is you can now specify a time to deliver the
messages, so make sure you put that, make
it relevant to your application.
So, messages that would've expired don't actually
end up getting delivered and you'll reduce
the load that way as well.
And people who turn on their handsets later
on in the morning.
OK.
I think that covers that one.
Does anyone else have a question from inside
the Hangout?
>>Sparky: Alright.
We got Ravi.
Ravi, what's up?
>>Ravi: Hi, guys.
How are you doing?
>>Sparky: Good.
Thank you very much.
>>Ravi: Yeah.
I've been part of Google Hangouts the week
before and yeah, I'm really excited to join
you guys back again.
Not to waste any more time, but I just had
a quick question.
I don't know if this sounds really stupid,
but pardon me if it does.
[laughs] I have an application which we're
extending into a tablet edition and I don't
know.
What's really haunting us is the screen resolutions
where as for the developer guide, given in
developer.android.com, the actual screen sizes
were differentiated or general sizes were
small, normal, large, and extra-large.
And as for the density, there's LDPI, MDPI,
HDPI, and XHDPI.
In this instance, I see some of the seven-inch
tablet devices, or some of the devices which
has a seven-inch screen taking HDPI assets,
whereas some devices which are having a four
point seven inch screen, such as S3 is taking
XHDPI assets.
I'm not quite sure what strategy I just need
to lay in order to fit the best layout with
the best assets.
>>Rich: Yeah, that's exactly right.
Devices [inaudible].
Have you seen any support in multiple screens
page in android developer.com?
It gives a good outline of which device [inaudible].
[pause]
>>Sparky: Is Ravi still--?
>>Ravi: I have seen the developer's Android
site and I've also seen the supporting multiple
screens and stuff.
But I mean, when I am actually doing some
development and it's OK when we are doing
it via an emulator and checking it over some
part of your test devices, but when we send
the app over the market, Android devices are
being in thousands of numbers and we are not,
we are unable to figure the way where we need
to strategize the way.
So, in some cases, we just need to specifically
set some standards for a specific device and
release the APK to the consumer and send it
to air, which is taking hundreds of business,
I mean, developer hours.
So, how am I think if you would help on this?
>>Nick: So, what's the issue you're facing?
>>Al: I get the impression from Ravi that
one of the things that's providing a bit of
confusion is the difference between densities
of assets and screen sizes.
It's best if you think of those as two different
things.
So, the density of assets is about how much
detail you want.
And the screen size is your layout that you
want to incorporate.
So that way, when you come across something
like an S3, it's using the high-density assets
but it's still using the right layout for
its size screen.
>>Ravi: Right.
>>Sparky: Yeah, exactly.
So, to sort of riff on what Al is saying,
basically, you have say a visual thing like
a button background or an icon.
And you say, "I want this thing to be about
two centimeters across."
And then, you design a bitmap that measures
about two centimeters across in each of say,
three or four bitmap or pixel densities.
So, you say this thing is at 300 dots per
inch or 200 dots per inch or 160 dots per
inch.
This is how many pixels across the image needs
to be in order to measure say, two centimeters
in real distances.
And so, you just have different versions of
every visual asset and let the Android device
know its own screen density and say, OK, I
am an XDPI, XHDPI device.
I will pick this one.
Or, I am an NDPI device.
I'll pick that one.
And you can then trust that when that thing
has gone on screen, that is approximately
two centimeters across, subject to minor variations
because of the different size buckets.
And then, so you size your assets for the
density and you size your layouts for the
actual size.
So you say, I want, this is the layout I want
to use and this screen actually physically
measures seven inches across, or ten inches
across, or whatever.
And then rely on the device to pick and choose
the right combination of layout per its screen
size and the individual asset elements based
on its pixel density.
Did that make sense?
>>Nick: An easier way to do that is whenever
you're doing your layouts, make sure you're
working in DIPS 'cause that lets you not think
about density, just think about size when
you do your screen layout.
And make sure you're working in density independent
pixels for all the layouts.
>>Ravi: Uhh, yeah.
But when I'm doing the assets, the screen
resolution which I use for the assets says
like, as specified in developer.android.com,
which is a normal screen has 470 by 320.
And that screen has 640 by 480.
And using this aspect ratio, we are designing
the assets where you cannot expect all MDPI
devices would be having this same screen resolution.
So, I think this is where I am making a mistake.
>>Al: Yeah.
I mean, for the sizes you've quoted are the
screen sizes, not the densities.
So, that would define your layout.
The densities are if you look on the same
page, it'll say MDPI and the range is about
150 to 200 dots per inch.
>>Ravi: Right.
>>Al: And that's what you use to determine
your asset sizes and how much detail you wanna
put in those assets.
The sizes you're talking about, the 640, 480,
the 470, 320, that's for designing the actual
whole layout of the screen rather than designing
your assets and how much detail you want to
appear in those assets.
>>Ravi: Right.
I got it now.
Yeah.
>>Nick: The raw pixel dimensions as well,
like something about normalcy.
I guess the most common thing out there, it's
a normal high-density screen.
And I wouldn't ever think about it, the dimensions,
so it's always, always, always think about
how big that is in DIPS.
And when you're doing your design, use the
value, the DIPS value, as the pixel dimensions.
>>Al: Fortunately, the screen support document
does talk about DPs rather than actual pixels.
So, hopefully that's reinforcing Nick's message.
>>Nick: Yeah, there's a great training class
as well.
So, that should probably give more background
>>Ravi: Alright.
That's brilliant, guys.
>>Sparky: And of course if you have further
questions, feel free to look us up on Google+
and send a little message to Google+ or something
like that.
Or, take your question to StackOverflow or
to the Android Developers Forum, where people
will be happy to help answer your questions
for you there as well.
>>Ravi: Thank you.
>>Sparky: Alright.
Does anyone else want to ask us a question
in the forum before we tune in to the Moderator
again?
>>Al: I've got one to throw across to Matt.
I saw the announcement yesterday about Google
TV rolling out to Germany, France, and The
Netherlands.
Do you know if that's going to be the same
Android version as is currently available
on the Sony player in the UK and the States?
>>Matt: So, it'll be a different version.
The versions being released in the UK, Germany,
the Netherlands is gonna be different from
the one in the States.
There's a couple of bits they've got over
there that we haven't got quite yet over here.
Yeah, it will be different, but only slightly.
>>Al: Cool.
Is there somewhere gonna be put out that says
what the differences will be so that people
coating for global Google TV can tweak their
apps accordingly?
>>Matt: I will make sure that that happens,
but ultimately it'll be things like the EPG
content supplier that's not gonna be there
and things like that.
Yeah, and we'll eventually bring it out.
Yeah, but I'll make sure it ends up somewhere.
>>Al: Cool, thanks.
>>Matt: No worries.
What are you working on?
Can I ask?
>>Al: I was looking at working on some social
backed applications with Google TV.
So, chatting about TV shows but using second
screen on a phone and things like that.
But if the EPG stuff isn't around, it makes
it a little difficult to determine which programs
on and therefore, get hash tags and stuff
relating to that program.
But I can tweak it.
There's other ways of approaching it.
And it was a bit of a shock to see that there's
no Google+ app for Google TV yet.
>>Matt: Yes, I know.
>>Sparky: I suppose you could code source
that, couldn't you Al?
You could just monitor which tags are out
there and when a whole bunch in one particular
theme start appearing, you can guess that
that show has begun.
>>Al: Yeah.
The only issue with that comes when you got
people that are watching the less popular
channels 'cause you get the popular TV program,
like "X Factor" or some talent show.
You get someone who's watching it--.
[pause]
>>Matt: I think there's a number of ways you
can kind of let go with it.
I think e-pop is the main one that's, that
they really target specific shows in their
apps.
So, yeah, it'll be really interesting to see
what you come up with.
>>Al: I'll put you on the beta list.
>>Matt: I look forward to that.
>>Sparky: And when you peddle the idea, remember
that you heard it here first so you can't
sue us.
[laughter]
>>Al: I'm sure in the States it's patented
already somewhere.
>>Sparky: So, I wanted to ask Matt, since
you were talking about Google TV a little
bit, you wanna just give us like the quick,
the 10,000 foot overview of what is in the
new Google TV platform and how does it relate
to Android?
What version is it based on?
And what new capabilities does it give us?
>>Matt: So, at the moment, Google TV is running
three point two, so it's still Honeycomb.
But essentially, added a load of extra work
for media codecs, so it means that we've gotten
a load of extra hooks for people with [inaudible]
media, so you can actually work out what the
quality of the stream is.
We're also adding in support for like, PlayReady
DRM as well as allowing content suppliers
to create their own DRM solutions.
We've also got libraries to help you set your
screen applications, so you can easily integrate
it with phones, tablets, and then you can
either communicate over a socket or use intents.
Essentially you can [inaudible] on the TV
or on the mobile phone.
And we're just developing a load of extra
tools so it can actually help develop the
tablet UI.
We're desperate to make sure they're not just
getting tablet UIs ported across without focus
states being enabled, which obviously, for
the TV that relies on [inaudible] is quite
important.
So, yeah.
And we're at the moment, I mean, our focus
is just getting international launch going
in Paris, Germany, Netherlands, and the UK.
I've just come from IFA in Berlin where we've
just had Samsung announce the [inaudible]
will be launching in the UK and hopefully
other countries soon.
My sense is we'll actually be going international
I hope.
So, yeah.
There's lots of stuff going on at the moment.
Lots and lots of devices coming out, so lots
of interest all over the place.
>>Sparky: That's fantastic.
Now, a couple of minutes ago when you mentioned
content providers choosing their own DRM solutions,
I assume that you're talking about people
who provide TV shows and stuff, not services
that say, front databases, right?
Is that right?
Different kind of content provider?
>>Matt: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Definitely.
My apologies.
Yeah, definitely.
Anyone who's got video or audio content and
they've got their own DRM solution.
Ultimately, it's a neat area, but you'd be
surprised at the number of people that have
niche content that they're publishing.
Like, we've got a company that's in the US
that distributes Korean TV shows and we had
them at Google IO and their main demonstration
show was "Sex in the City" but with guys instead
of women.
And apparently, it's really, really popular
in the US.
So, yeah.
Interesting.
>>Sparky: Alright.
>>Al: You haven't got a starring role in that,
have you, Matt?
>>Matt: Not yet, no, I'm working on it.
I'm emailing and pulling the right strings.
Soon.
[laughs]
>>Sparky: All right.
Let's take another one from the Moderator.
It's been a little while.
Let's see.
Vmail says, "Can we make application which
acts like an application locker?
Other applications only get accessible after
providing password, if yes, can you provide
a hint, etc."
Well, maybe.
I mean, one of the things to keep in mind
is that our terms of use say that you can't
provide an application that functions as app
store and distribute it through Google Play.
So, if it's gonna be like an app store, you
would have to distribute it some other way.
We're perfectly OK with you writing those
apps.
You just can't distribute them through us.
The other thing is, I suppose, yeah, sure.
You could tie it into, for example, the license
verification library, but where you gonna
say something Al?
>>Nick: I heard the question slight differently.
I heard it more like with some device.
So, you can actually implement let's say,
some kind of launcher, I think, to, it's the
launcher which opens up the shortcuts to launch
all the apps.
So, if you wanted to provide a customized
experience, which requires a password to do
that, you can open it out of the launcher.
>>Rich: But at the same time, you'd have to
be very careful because we do have a clause
in the developer distribution agreement which
means, which states you're not allowed to
interfere with the other applications, the
way they work, or the data that they use.
So, when you're trying to lock this application
behind a password, just be quite careful that
maybe it's still impossible to run the application
other manners so it shouldn't muck about with
the application data or anything to do with
the way the application itself is stored.
If any complaints come in saying that your
application is affecting their application,
then you could get taken down for it.
So, do it in a safe, family friendly manner.
>>Matt: See, I think I read this question
a third way, which was essentially detecting
before the application is actually launched
and then essentially throwing up a password
screen before that and then preventing it
from launching otherwise, if the password
isn't entered.
>>Rich: Yeah.
That would be a function of an [inaudible],
right?
>>Al: I mean, I read it a fourth way, which
is along the lines of using a password to
get access to content provider data.
So, is there a way of requiring one application
to provide a password before it can get access
to data from a content provider from a second
application?
>>Rich: OK.
Well, Vmail, you've divided us four ways somehow.
[laughter]
>>Yossi: I think what he means is there used
to be a way to see the ActivityManager log
file, see the system logs and see the events
being brought against result to see if it's
being launched.
And when the activity was being launched,
we used to send the intent and show your log
screen.
And when there was interest, the logcat is
now blocked.
So, no one can really see the system log even
if they have permission.
So, application locker won't work and they
have the same issue.
Basically, you just look for the package after
you set the lock feature, then you set the
package name and the logcat.
And then when the intent is broadcasted, then
you show your own screen instead of the app
screen.
>>Nick: So it sits on top of it?
>>Yossi: Yeah.
>>Rich: It sits on top of it.
So if you don't get the password right, you
kill the application?
>>Yossi: Yeah.
You don't kill the application, you just send
a cancel intent or send a home intent, so
the apps won't get actually the wrong time.
>>Nick: So, you can't do that anymore.
So, I guess if you were gonna go the launcher
route, I'd look at the source for launcher
two, which is in AOSP and use that as a starting
point.
And beyond that, I guess we need some more
details on what you're exactly trying to achieve.
>>Rich: Yeah.
That's fair enough.
>>Nick: Thanks.
>>Rich: Next.
>>Sparky: Anybody else?
>>Al: I've got one for Nick and Rich.
Can we see what's going on in the Hackathon?
>>Rich: Yeah, I'll try and get a mobile device
through there in a minute.
>>Al: Cool.
>>Rich: Nick's laptop, I'll see if I can join.
We've got one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, ten.
We're already fully booked.
We got all ten users in the stream right now.
So, I might just take this device with me
and hope this doesn't--.
No, there's already ten people in the Hangout.
>>Yossi: OK.
>>Rich: So, if you leave the Hangout, you'll
be able to see.
[laughter]
>>Al: If you tell me that you need the space,
I'm quite happy to drop out.
>>Rich: No, it's fine.
We'll leave it to the last five or ten minutes
of the Hangout 'cause there's a good chance
we'll drop out while talking around the building.
And then I'll take this laptop and go into
the Hackathon space and you'll be able to
see it that way.
>>Al: Cool.
Thanks.
>>Rich: We'll jump out of there and see what's
going on.
>>Yossi: You can see a few pictures on my
Google+ page.
>>Rich: If you follow Yossi on Google+.
[laughter]
OK, so we'll just go to the next question.
Have you got on lined up there, Sparky?
>>Sparky: I do.
Let's see.
How to manage the ICS incremental use of memory
for high density graphics?
My apps are using up to 20 mgs pre-ICS, but
with ICS it goes up to 60 mgs plus.
That's too much.
Heavy opps crashes due to memory, etc.
Is there not something that you can put into
your manifest that says "I want to use an
extra big system heap," that you probably
shouldn't use?
But--.
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Sparky: Otherwise--.
>>Rich: It sounds like he might be storing
more tif files or something in your XHTPI
folder.
What, 60 megabytes of graphics?
>>Nick: So, on this question let's see how
many ways it divides us.
So, he thinks something's changed in ICS with
memory handling, or is he just saying like,
the ICS era with HD graphic, higher resolution,
how do you guys interpret it?
>>Rich: I interpret it as the latter one,
but now we're going for HD graphics.
>>Nick: Yeah, so each of these devices with
the higher resolution screens don't really
have a higher per app memory that you can
get, can't you, by the memory info class?
I can't remember the name of the class.
Physical attribution query and say what's
my limit.
It's a good way to do this kind of thing,
is to use empty caches so that there's a first
level where you're caching it to in memory
cache.
If that cache gets full, you're putting it
out to disk and so on.
And there's a bunch of great implementations
of that, most of them based on LIU caches.
So, there's a good talk at Google IO by Jeff
Sharky about writing apps which go through
such a cache mutation.
And that talks about how you would size it
based on memory available, right?
So, that's one strategy behind a clever caching
system.
Any other advice you guys?
>>Rich: Al Sutton's just put a link to memory
[ unintelligible ] memory class.
>>Nick: Get memory class, that's it.
>>Rich: Oh, is that--?
>>Al: That one will give you all the details
about what you got available.
>>Nick: Yeah.
And I think Jeff's talk says about using the
memory available to apps to size your cache.
So you might wanna keep, say, half of your
memory available for images.
But it depends what your app is doing.
>>Al: There's also the recycling bitmap information,
which might be useful if there are a lot of
bitmaps being held around in memory.
>>Rich: Yes.
They have a good blog post on that at Android
developer's blog.
>>Nick: Yeah.
Reuse bit map objects and recycle it as soon
as you can.
I think Chris Baynes also has a great recycling
bitmap cache implementation on GitHub if anyone
would be bored with their internet and find
a link to Chris Baynes', uh, GitHub.
That would be most appreciated.
I think that's it.
A nice solution.
[pause]
>>Matt: I was saying there's 60 megabytes
sounds a lot.
>>Nick: Yeah.
My original worry with that as well, that
you're just opening large sized bitmaps and
porting the large sized bitmap in memory and
then resizing it when you're setting it.
So, I definitely don't do that.
Definitely only open, do the thing where you
get the bitmap bounds and only open it for
a certain size at which you want to present
it.
So, never, keep it [unintelligible] and resize
it, especially if you're doing a custom drawing
where you're actually resizing it in your
own drawing and things like that.
Don't forget about doing that.
>>Matt: Another thing to consider, I think
it was in the Greendroid bitmap recycling,
it's got a listener for memory warnings.
And then the minute they receive that, they
clear out their bitmap cache.
And I don't know whether that's good as an
absolute last resort or whether you just should
be avoiding that situation at all costs and
not try and account for, I don't know.
>>Nick: And as the new callback's introduced
in ICS, right, on trim memory, which will
get the full on load memory.
So this is all covered in that talk from Jeff
Sharky in IO.
So, I strongly encourage you to check that
out.
Yeah, which talks about that's the point at
which you trim out your cache.
>>Rich: Yeah.
Sounds good.
Yeah, the app should never get to the point
where it crashes anyway.
>>Sparky: I could get behind that.
>>Rich: What was that, Sparky?
>>Sparky: Just saying, I think I could definitely
get behind that last comment of yours, the
app shouldn't get to the point where it crashes.
I like that.
I think I can live with that advice.
>>Nick: Thanks.
>>Rich: The link?
Oh, it's a YouTube link for the Jeff Sharky's
IO talk.
You can also find the IO--
>>Yossi: I also posted on the thread, the
memory--.
>>Nick: Cool.
Any more live questions?
Silence.
>>Rich: We've gotten loads more appearing
in the Moderator, though.
Let's go have a look.
Offline documentation for Android four point
one so we can share it with other developers.
He's downloaded it three times, but each time
the Android training is still lots of Android
[inaudible].
I think this is more likely because--.
>>Sparky: It probably hasn't changed.
>>Rich: Haven't had new classes added to Android
training for four point one.
But maybe you already, maybe you've spotted
a class that is online that isn't offline.
But it is most likely that we just haven't
added any new classes since the package was
built.
>>Sparky: My understanding is that each time
we push an SDK release, the Docs team rolls
up the documentation site and they put that
in the SDK as well.
I think that's what's, I think that's what
they told me.
>>Al: There's also partly Android Open Source
Project, there's some training documentation
all the development pulls are in there as
well.
So, if it does look like there's a problem,
there's the ability to contribute back to
the AOSP and make tweaks in that that hopeful
get rolled into the next release.
[pause]
>>Sparky: Cool.
>>Nick: The SDK is updated.
You'll get the latest cut then.
[pause]
>>Sparky: So, in light of that, I would guess
that if he's not seeing any new classes, it
may just be that there aren't any, unless
he can identify something that's missing.
I would go with that.
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Sparky: Rich, you're right.
The questions are flowing in here.
RobM wants to know, looking for tips on developing
on lock screen widget.
There isn't a lot of documentation on that.
However, I did find some information about
it on StackOverflow.
I just found it by searching for it, so you
probably can, too.
Or if you look back in the archives of these
Hangouts.
Go back maybe two or three months.
I think you may find it there.
So, we had a--.
>>Nick: [ inaudible ] widget, then I think
most of the app posts which tend to work with
standard widget APIs they use, it should be
exactly the same as creating a fresh, new
widget, right?
>>Sparky: Yeah, now that you mention it, I
think the question was that we have some information
about lock screen widgets that are officially
supported for Honeycomb and beyond.
And one of the objections that people have
is they say, "Oh, I want my lock screen to
work on Gingerbread and before as well."
And that's where you have to get into the
unofficial stuff and look at what the people
have done on StackOverflow.
So, one of the authors of one of the leading
lock screen packages basically posted to StackOverflow
and said, "This is how I did it."
>>Yossi: Why not try and use the AOC code.
Try to see how it's built on the version you
want to implement.
Just extend it to what you want to change.
Maybe the views and basically have the base
class already implemented on your application.
[pause]
>>Sparky: That's a pretty good idea.
Should we move on to the next one?
Let's see.
>>Rich: Oh, but Ravi was trying to ask a question
when I was talking about, started asking the
thing from the Moderator.
Do you want to ask your question, Ravi?
>>Ravi: Yeah.
I've been posting it on chat, actually.
That's fine.
I can ask here.
I heard it from Google IO that Android would
be strictly monitoring the applications that
were paid on Google Play.
And someone would be downloading and instantly
the APKs will be having some strict reinforcements
and considering a downloaded application.
So, what has happened with it, I mean, I haven't
seen any restrictions of people downloading
applications from third-party sites and just
installing them on their phones.
>>Al: I think that's related to the encryption
that was coming in Jellybean for paid APKs.
>>Sparky: Well, the encryption is in, I think.
>>Al: There were some issues that had it that
it was backed out for a bit, but I think it
is back again.
>>Ravi: Oh, right.
So, the devices which are supporting four
point one and less than four point one will
not be having any kind of restrictions over
these stuff if I am true.
>>Sparky: I don't think that there's much
that we can do for devices that are running
a release of the OS that comes before it knows
about the encryption because how would it?
I mean, I guess, I don't know.
I suppose if we updated the market client
or the Google Play client, maybe you could.
>>Nick: Changes to packet manager involved
as well.
>>Sparky: OK.
>>Nick: You can't [inaudible]
>>Rich: It's through Jellybean only and upwards.
>>Sparky: Yeah, that's the problem with those
darn legacy devices.
Screw up all your wonderful new technology.
>>Nick: I'll be interested to hear, so, what
is it that you heard at Google IO?
Was it about the bad encryptions, is that
what you're asking about?
The install from unsecure sources.
>>Ravi: Umm, no.
When I just watched the launch of Nexus 7,
which is about the Jellybean, yeah.
That's where it is.
[pause]
>>Rich: Next.
>>Sparky: Next.
OK.
Houdini has a couple of questions following
up from previous discussions.
He was talking about the one-by-one settings
widgets saying isn't that really a shortcut
because it can be placed in a folder, which
I thought was exclusive to shortcuts?
Back to your original question, how do you
create a config activity for a shortcut?
And then he asks a related question, which
is, he says, my main use case for creating
shortcuts is replicating place on hold screen
that is on the overflow menu for the people
app.
How can you do that without the widget so
he can skip shortcuts altogether?
>>Al: There is actually a StackOverflow answer
for creating shortcuts there.
>>Rich: Yeah, the key is to get the create
shortcuts permission, isn't it?
>>Al: Yeah.
>>Rich: So, just look for, go for search for
create shortcut permission.
>>Al: Install shorts.
>>Rich: They have a widget which creates shortcuts,
I think.
>>Nick: [ inaudible ] widget right between
[ inaudible ].
>>Rich: Is there a way to do the same widget
so it can skip shortcuts?
No.
There's no way inside your application of
having a button that you press which [inaudible].
>>Nick: [inaudible].
>>Sparky: The user has to install the widget,
right?
Is that right?
>>Rich: Yeah.
I think we actually agreed on that one, that
that's the question he asking.
Yeah, he's been trying to ask this question
since we got here, I think.
Trying to find the buttons that add widgets
to the home screen.
>>Nick: So, there is an API for adding shortcuts
or not?
>>Rich: Yeah.
Plenty of widgets.
Interesting, though.
[buzzing]
OK.
We had a little bit of interference.
>>Sparky: [inaudible].
So, just say the app won't do anything unless
you install a widget.
And then, he'll have his widgets.
>>Rich: Or just a lot of uninstalled apps
without ratings.
But yeah, I think we got to the bottom of
it in the end and no, it's not possible.
Next.
[laughs]
>>Sparky: Joined by a couple of new people
live on the Hangout.
We got Prakash.
We got Quint.
You guys have anything you wanna talk about
here on the Hangout?
[pause]
OK.
We'll let them think about that.
Maybe take another question from the Moderator.
So, Sebastian says, "I want to make a custom
calendar view wherein I can show events match
fixtures in date cells.
How should I go about it?
Thanks."
>>Nick: Probably start from the calendar view
widget in AOSP.
>>Sparky: So, are you thinking like take that
in subclasses and, or--?
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Sparky: Can you just override layouts, maybe?
Like how much customization do you think is
necessary to do something with that?
>>Nick: It depends what you're trying to do.
You might even be better off going from the
calendar app itself.
It depends what you're trying to achieve.
I don't, I'm not quite clear on exactly what
he's trying to achieve.
>>Yossi: He's trying to show calendar--.
>>Matt: And what about the Google for IO app
as well?
That might be a good one if that's sort of
what you wanted to implement.
>>Sparky: OK.
So, a couple of good sources.
Look at the AOSP calendar app or the Google
IO app.
>>Nick: Yeah, I'd probably start with calendar
which is something similar, but the actual
calendar, if you go to that month view, it
sounds like what you want, which draws the
month and has little dots marking events.
I'd see what I could learn, borrow, steal
from that.
>>Sparky: We had a question not too long ago,
a month or two, where somebody wanted basically
wanted to take their own private calendar
data and mash it up with Android calendar
data and display it in a calendar.
And I seem to recall that what we came up
with at the time was more or less, they would
have to create their own UI for it.
That we didn't have a way to just enhance
the existing UI of the existing app.
So, it's the case that the way to do this
is gonna be to look at the source code of
one of these already published date-viewing
apps, IO calendar, whatever and actually get,
really get down in there into the UI and basically
copy slash reinvent the UI.
[pause]
OK.
"Can I make an Android app for just three
people to have without putting it in the store?"
Yes, absolutely.
We call that side-loading, which basically
is installing by a means other than Google
Play.
And in order to support side-loading, your
users have to go into settings and from settings,
go into security and select the checkbox that
says "unknown sources."
In this case, unknown sources is pretty much
anything but the Google Play store.
Once they do that, the easiest way to give
just three people your APK is to attach it
to an email and email it to them.
When they read the email on their device,
then the package manager will offer to install
it.
Clear?
I think?
>>Nick: And as you get increasingly sophisticated
there's other things you can do.
So, if it's just small, like something like
Google Drive or drop boxes, it's great for
all your sharing-related tools, but if you
get more requirements, like have more tested,
more people you want to distribute it out
to, there's other solutions out there like
there's one called Floppy App, which is, I've
heard a lot of people using.
So you can use that to distribute your apps
to other people.
It's kind of like a private store.
>>Sparky: Hmm.
When you said that, what I immediately thought
of was Hoccer, which I seem to recall was
popular a couple years ago as a way of sharing
things with people.
Are those guys still around?
>>Nick: I don't know.
I haven't heard from them in a while.
>>Sparky: That was the other thing.
It was a little bit like Bump, only it worked
over a distance, where you had your accelerometer
and you took your device and you kind of went
"foop", like that, almost like you're throwing
a Frisbee and they could catch it.
And the devices would talk to the server and
correlate the accelerometer readings and figure
out who threw what to whom.
Doesn't ring a bell with anyone?
H-O-C-C-E-R.
>>Al: It doesn't with me, but a quick thought
is if you're developing an Android app, you
can use NFCB to send a URL between devices.
So, if you wanted a quick way to do it, host
the APK on the web server and update the app
so that NFCB sends a URL across the other
device should be able to woken it up and install
it.
>>Sparky: I thought about that.
I also thought that a small developer who's
gonna get an APTK to a couple of friends quickly
is more likely to have email than a web server.
>>Al: True.
True.
>>Nick: I think the [ inaudible ] drive is
the way to go here.
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Sparky: Google Drive.
Good one.
I hadn't think, you know, that one even slipped
my mind.
That's a great answer, too.
>>Nick: Yeah, I like Google Drive 'cause then
you can even update it and make sure everyone
has the latest version and all that good stuff.
>>Sparky: OK.
All these questions that keep on splitting
our opinion in multiple different ways.
>>Al: There's never one right answer, just
a whole series of suggestions, which is the
way it should be.
>>Sparky: Right.
Let's see.
You people have to stop voting on these questions.
New questions are coming in and they're getting
voted up and filtering to the top of my list
on the Moderator.
Maybe in the future, I'll, maybe in the future
I'll lock the Moderator just before we start
the Hangout.
So, a word to the wary, get your questions
in before the Hangout begins if you want an
informed answer.
"I just switched from C2M to GCM, but sometimes
my messages don't get delivered to all devices
when sending them as a batch.
The devices are all linked to the same Google
account.
Does that mean it will only deliver them to
one?"
>>Al: No, GCM doesn't guarantee delivery of
any message.
So--.
>>Sparky: I am not aware that it restricts
multiple devices on the same account from
each receiving the message.
I hadn't heard anything about that.
So, I would guess that's probably not the
case.
It may just be vagaries of delivery.
>>Rich: Lots of applications that you have
installed, you'll get notifications across
all your devices at the same time with GCM.
As long as you've got the ID right as the
device sets up and registers your server.
You may have issues that you're not correctly
supporting the C2DM and GCM at the same time.
Some devices are still on the C2DM version
of your client and some devices have upgraded
to the GCM version of your client.
Maybe one or the other aren't getting the
messages--.
>>Nick: [ inaudible ].
>>Rich: Yeah.
Boy, you've got to support both C2DM and GCM
and both end points on our server so we can
send the right message to the right clients.
So, you'll be sending two sets of messages
if you're still doing the upgrade, especially
if you've just switched over.
It's likely to fall into that bucket.
So, make sure you've got an old client that's
still on C2DM and a new client that's on GCM
when you're doing the test, I would say.
If it's not that, then yeah, what Al said
that we don't guarantee delivery.
But it's definitely not down to us excluding
devices because they're on the same Google
account.
Andrew Kenny has one other question.
He also asks, "If I have a grid view, how
can I get the last rows recentered if I have
an odd number of items to the grid?"
Apparently it's in the left-hand column of
the other items.
I don't actually have an answer.
In the left-hand column unless you can add
a footer to grid view like you can on list
views.
Maybe you can add a footer item if you've
got an odd number of items, you can put it
in the footer.
Any suggestions from the Hangout?
>>Nick: Add a spacer item?
>>Yossi: Yeah.
Maybe [ inaudible ]. Just as a filler?
>>Rich: Just as a filler?
So, you'd be in the right-hand column, yeah.
But he wants it centered in the middle.
>>Nick: But I'm saying it's just like three
columns and then you could add one.
>>Rich: Oh, there's three columns?
Yeah, that's not bad.
Yeah.
I was imagining two and then left and right
and swap.
>>Nick: Yeah, right.
Yeah.
>>Yossi: He wants it centered, so it has--.
>>Nick: I would say this sounds like a custom
layout.
You probably want to extend grid view and
change some of its layout attributes and center
the last little line.
>>Sparky: I haven't done this with grid view,
but I had a question a little while back where
somebody wanted to center an even number of,
well, a mix of even, odd numbers of elements--in
this case, buttons--in a relative layout.
And what I suggested was creating an invisible,
or a non-visible, text view.
Center that and then place all the other elements
relative to that.
So, a spacer item or an invisible view of
some kind, may be a way to go here.
>>Nick: I like the idea of extending grid
view.
[inaudible].
I think that fills that.
>>Rich: Extend the grid view.
>>Nick: Yeah.
Plus it will work nicely with the adapter
as well, [inaudible] background of the [inaudible].
There we go.
Announced.
>>Rich: I was thinking, yeah.
That's fine.
Well, that was the last question from the
Moderator unless someone else has snuck one
in whilst--.
>>Sparky: I got a bunch more, actually.
>>Rich: No.
Well, we've only got three minutes left of
the Hangout and I was gonna do a quick run
round to the--.
>>Nick: Yeah, do it.
>>Sparky: Well, why don't I through some of
these questions while you take a walk maybe?
>>Rich: OK.
I'm unplugging from the Ethernet, so that
might drop me off for a start, but I'll just
re--.
[laughter]
>>Sparky: He is frozen.
So we've got another question on the Moderator
here.
It says, we "described how to make use of
a drawer but didn't document it or provide
any implementation advice."
Well, that's true.
It's so new that basically the Android team
had not, or the framework team had not yet
caught up with the practice.
So, look ion Stack Overflow.
There's some Stack Overflow threads that give
links to projects that implement various versions
of the left-hand drawer.
And look--.
>>Al: And then obviously--.
>>Sparky: Look to the YouTube application
as the way that we recommend that it be implemented
in terms of behavior.
Oh, I see some motion there from, is that
Rich?
>>Rich: Yeah, I'm sure you can see that it's
a beautiful day here in Tel Aviv.
I just thought I'd stop on the balcony for
a second to make you all kind of jealous.
When was the last time you saw a sky like
that in London?
>>Sparky: It's been a while since I saw one
in--.
>>Rich: And the palm trees.
OK.
>>Sparky: Let's see.
I'll take another question from the Moderator
while he's walking.
"In my UI thread, I started a task to do some
long time calculations.
How can I weight properly in the UI thread
to get info about finishing the task without
handlers?"
You can post progress updates from you async
task.
And you can also complete the task by doing
something on post execute.
>>Al: We have a cardboard Android.
>>Sparky: Cardboard Android.
Rich, what are we looking at?
>>Al: I have a feeling they've just frozen.
>>Sparky: Uh-oh.
Well, they stepped into a, they stepped into
a lion's den of developers there.
They're probably using every wi-fi channel.
[pause]
Got a couple of new people in the call.
We got Falco Richter.
Any news from Falco?
OK.
[pause]
Do we recommend creating a library Android
project to validate--?
[pause]
Is always a good idea.
Maybe not for something like a spinner or
a drop-down list, but if you're taking anything
from a text view or a text edit, definitely
validate your--
>>Al: And they're back in Israel.
>>Rich: OK, we are back.
Here's the Hackathon happening in the college
right now with [ inaudible ].
[background chatter]
This is, this is the Android developer Office
Hours.
Hey guys.
What projects are you working on?
>>Male #1: I'm working on--.
Hi.
I working on, it's a kind of application that
integrates Google Drive API to distribute
files with [unintelligible] events.
If you're attending a Google IO, then you
don't have to download the application, it
will drop inside your Google Drive.
>>Rich: Thanks very much.
Does anyone want to see what other project
bits are going on?
Or, do you wanna finish it off there?
>>Al: No, keep going round the room.
It sounds interesting.
>>Rich: OK.
Would anyone else like to tell the world what
project they're working on at the moment?
[background chatter]
Yeah?
Yeah.
What project's you working on?
>>Male #2: [inaudible].
We're doing dog feeding.
>>Rich: Dog feeding?
>>Male #2: Yeah.
Poor dogs.
No, it's basically an application that once
installed in all your device, will choose
whatever products you want to subscribe to.
Every time the machine builds a new version,
it uploads everything to your drive and then
has it installed on your devices, beta users,
[inaudible].
[background chatter]
>>Rich: Excellent.
That's actually guests Google Drive slash
Android Hackathon.
So, lots of projects going on.
Google Drive projects as well.
It's an excellent addition to your build system,
will upload your files as you're building
them straight to Google Drive and that way
users test them, the latest version of the
apps as they're being built.
We'll leave it at that.
We're way over time already.
But--.
>>Al: Thanks for the tour.
>>Male #3: Only a few people?
>>Rich: Yeah, it's all right.
Well, thank you all very much.
We're gonna leave you there and we'll catch
you again next Wednesday.
>>Al: Thanks, guys.
>>Sparky: Alright.
Thanks everyone for showing up.
Once again, giving us another great excuse
to fill your heads with lots of ideas about
Android development.
And we'll join you again at the same two o'clock
UK time, three o'clock Central European time
next Wednesday.
Take care everyone.
>>Rich: Until next week.
See ya.
>>Al: Bye.